обласних змагань з усіх треба
нашого сина стеб і є наша дитинка
вважати це особистий син сталіна чубенка
степан знак посмішка 2014
коли краматорських вікон і все під контролем
проросійських сепаратистів
батька обожню че за х стоїть і
патріотичне la що вона у сина адже
правила його зміцнювали днів, а петля дві
лінії місця з тебе вони ковані по парі
дав вирослих додому поїхавши через
купівля ван та донецьк
та його і за 3 мани я до нас раз повели у
їх захопив за кабула зустрічка
жовто-блакитний
і кулі футбольному клубу карпати які йому
підірвав і в верби нуцци фавни виявилося
а зло чину укушу як сина батька обійшли
підсилка леті донецькому а ти бл аналог
ирина kiss апарат з типу відома ти про
містицизму хід дружині стеб і правду бачка
іди знала чути через два ти ж не
живить до початку kotova гавкіт а потім
розстріляли раз по вілли
самі сепаратисти руки за спиною були
сорокою за спинами був і зв'язування
скотчем на голові футболка 5 пострілявши
влаштував оружня на дорослих
ну не знаю я їх назвати мужик як мужик
б так настоїв на ставши б стріляти в
довжину тіла степан з апарати 100 бачив
[ __ ] очерету через три місяці тут
волосся також що перебуває чого підлоги не
плескати простих на вигляд мати батькам про
його місяця захід дружина алла всього ніхто
так і на труби теж щоб монетах дуже
8 форматі що може допомогти
може розібрати озлобленого за раз в
офісі нам рушниця купер і буваєте давайте
дві дати на iq мову луїс початку провини в
донецьку та луганську та областях заданим
граматик організації служба рослих у
дітей по жуковій дуть обидва волонтери а
метеликом українські права зберігати та
на може пам'ятати синоді це науку
кованих територіях за дві рукою знай
донат 95 на похили їх pro tennis hd
живими і здоровими і вдома нам випад
кекулі
десь по вірталу цього разу побачив і
витягну їх про чоловік у валері таю копи
чому не споживав і під обстріли
адже ті хто їх там ранку мою в
полоне в пам'ятайте про степана g-банка
друзі друга Рід постіль проводьте
краматорська турнір з футболу я конвентах
заку плювався вбитий петлі так надовго
зал та шиття воротаря їм номер один міс
цілу клубу авангард друзі поважають
степана
героєм я коли ql є у карти ну
чого стане секунди і гірше тяги Кунаєва
розподільники
текст оnline акуліна ми на такій суспензіі
палаючі мабуть як би був ти стояла
переді мною не знає без грубих
не знаю що зробив посилання в руки на
вийняв у них щось його за роки ніхто з
нас для нас вінзор дибу ти живої спраги
знань через рік після смерті степу наші
bank йому народила органам народний герой
україни ціни тримала новгорода
адже української держави батька і хлопця
відсікає давида не до завершення
кримінальну право проти сина
карате в інших обіцяла і сама проковтнута
крем на це так званої днр тим часом
жити і дали батькам та допомагають з приводу
про стіб
мій образ буде
гітарист
і
смерть на
скажу брат улюблений берег